the hearty animals found
living north of the arctic circle live
in a constant dance with death
with a host of adaptations that help
them battle the lethally cold
temperatures
creating more body heat hibernating and
generally blocking the cold from getting
into the body
seem like the obvious approaches to
survive such cold climates
approaches taken by the large often
furry animals you normally think of when
you think of the arctic
but there's one animal that seems to
defy the logic that applies to most
other cold weather animals
an animal that almost certainly does not
come to mind when thinking of the frost
covered tundra
it's the only amphibian found north of
the arctic
circle its body wet and cold blooded
and if you came across it in the winter
time you would undoubtedly think you had
found a very dead
frog its body frozen solid eyes glazed
over
motionless but if you waited until
warmer conditions
you would see that frozen frog thaw out
gasp for air and bounce right back to
life
the wood frog doesn't survive in icy
climates by resisting the cold
but by embracing it it freezes and thaws
with the environment
with up to 70 of its body water freezing
with every cold snap
this is definitely a handy superpower
for the frog
but when it was discovered scientists
immediately saw the bigger story
utilizing these deep freeze abilities
could mean a longer shelf life for human
organs
a quest that has been out of reach since
the very first organ transplants
human organs outside the body don't last
very long
and when lives are hanging in the
balance even a few extra hours could
make all the difference
so how does the wood frog emerge from
its frozen state completely unharmed
what lessons can animals like this teach
us and is this ability something we can
harness for ourselves
[Music]
the wood frog is found across the forest
of north america
from the southern appalachian mountains
up to the tree line above the arctic
circle
in places that freeze and freeze hard
when winter starts to take hold the
frogs take shelter in the leaf litter of
the forest floor
they assume a crouched position with the
limbs drawn in
close to the body and their head lowered
this is the water holding position
and helps to reduce the amount of water
lost to evaporation over what could be
months of being frozen
ice formation begins in the extremities
then spreads
throughout the entire body cavity
surrounding the abdominal organs
eventually as much as 70 percent of the
frog's body water is frozen
and vital signs completely stop normally
ice formation like this should shred
tissue the crystals physically ripping
cells apart
freezing also normally wrecks cells by
affecting the flow of fluids into and
out of them
before ice forms inside cells it forms
in the spaces between them
which reduces the volume of liquid there
this increases the concentration of
dissolved salts and other ions
which causes water to rush out from the
cells to compensate
causing them to shrivel and die all of
this leading to a frosty demise
so to avoid this fate the wood frog's
body carefully orchestrates the entire
process to avoid ice crystallization and
dehydration in vital parts of the body
during the course of freezing they
change over their metabolism they
reorganize themselves
they're not damaged by the physical ice
they're not damaged by the anoxia
they're not damaged by the dehydration
to learn more about how the wood frog
can survive such an ordeal i talked to
dr
ken story professor of biochemistry and
wood frog expert at carleton university
so what happens when a frog is wet and
popping around yay
and it goes below zero ice starts to
penetrate
into the frog so the frog can't generate
heat itself it's a cold-blooded animal
it's a poignant
and so ice begins to push into the frog
this ice goes down veins and arteries
pushing blood ahead of it so eventually
if you take a stone frozen frog and you
cut off its legs and its arms which is
cruel
they have no blood the blood has all
been pushed into the center of the frog
where it's a huge lump of blood
that then freezes solid so frogs are
blood huge amounts of blood with large
amounts of glucose 400 millimolar
glucose
in the middle of them this glucose acts
as a protective molecule known as a
cryoprotectant
ice crystals are only made of pure water
but the temperature at which they start
to form depends on what else is in the
solution
anything suspended in water interferes
with water's ability to form the
hexagonal lattice work of ice crystals
cryoprotectants are molecules such as
alcohols or sugars
that animals can use to lower water's
freezing temperature
inside their bodies essentially a
biological antifreeze
if i gave you a frozen frog whoa you
would thaw it out
you would taste ah and it would taste
sweet
you can measure the glucose of a frog by
using a diabetes meter i don't know if
you're diabetic but
you just take a little test strip dip it
in the frog and then it says
oh my god you're dead go and see your
doctor immediately
because your blood glucose should be
four and the blood glucose you measure
out of the frog is 400.
once the frog's body senses that the
temperature is near freezing
the frog's liver begins to dump massive
amounts of glucose
into its bloodstream then glycerol
and alcohol and more glucose starts to
be packed into the frog cells to prevent
ice from forming there
and to prevent any drastic loss in
volume due to the dehydrating effects of
ice formation
at the same time water begins to move
out of the vital organ cells
and pools in the extracellular space ice
nucleating proteins
trigger the ice to freeze in these
specific places
in sheets between the skin and muscle
layers in small spaces such as the lens
of the eye or the ventricles of the
brain
everywhere except the critical organs
and cells
it can survive this period of no
circulation by reducing the metabolic
needs of cells
so they don't need much if any nutrients
and oxygen
and then spring comes the frog thaws and
all of its organs and bodily functions
are restored
nearly instantly and surprisingly the
wood frog doesn't just withstand the
cold but actually
depends on it they're adapted to being
frozen if you take a wood frog and you
keep it in the lab and you don't freeze
it
it does it just uses up all of its fuel
it uses up all of its muscle it uses up
all of its fat
it uses up all of its glycogen and it
dies
and even though frogs are amphibians and
humans are mammals we have
all of the same major organs so if a
frog can freeze itself completely solid
can we is there a way we can recreate
this ability
freezing organs and bringing them back
to life
in the big picture of history organ
transplants are a relatively recent
thing
it wasn't until 1954 that the first
human organ transplant was successfully
completed
a kidney transplanted from one identical
twin brother to the other
in 1967 the first liver and the first
heart were transplanted
and the era of organ transplants had
begun
in the u.s there are over a hundred
thousand people on a waiting list to
receive an organ transplant
but only around forty thousand
transplants are performed each year
seventeen people die per day waiting for
an organ that never came
much of this is due to a challenging
supply network constricted by the
inherent lifespan of organs once they've
been removed from the body
with the standard cooling methods a
liver or pancreas can survive for 12
hours outside the body
a heart for only six when an organ is
taken out
it's a race against the clock as cells
start dying from a lack of nutrients and
oxygen
but cooling them slows this process it
reduces the metabolism of the cells
so they need far less oxygen and
nutrients than they would
normally so the idea of freezing organs
to slow this process
even further making the organs last even
longer
became an immediate goal for doctors
shortly after the first liver transplant
researchers attempted the first frozen
preservation of livers
using glycerol as a cryoprotectant they
froze canine livers at negative 20
degrees celsius
for periods between 24 hours to 2 weeks
but when the livers were then
transplanted into healthy recipients
the animals only survived for a few
hours
the livers had suffered serious damage
to their cells
most notably to their blood vessels
years later
researchers tried again this time armed
with
more knowledge of freeze tolerant
animals like the wood frog
mimicking how the wood frog undergoes
freezing in nature
researchers infused rat livers with
glycerol and brought the temperature
down to just
negative three degrees celsius and did
so slowly
mirroring what happens to the frogs in
the wild
when these livers were transplanted back
into the original donors
they did produce bile and one animal
even lived for five days
but sadly none of the animals ultimately
survived
after decades of work in this field
researchers are coming to the conclusion
that ice is just too
damaging to tissues even in the presence
of cryoprotectants
the frogs are able to withstand such
freezing due to an amalgamation of
multiple adaptive strategies
anoxia tolerance dehydration tolerance
metabolic rate suppression
huge amounts of cryoprotectants targeted
ice nucleating proteins
we will struggle for a long time to
recreate all of these elements
working in perfect unison inside organs
each with different sizes
metabolic requirements and cell types i
ask dr
story if he thinks it will ever be
possible to mimic the frozen frog's
ability in organ preservation
if we put in time energy and money on
frozen frogs learned
everything and then froze human organs
yes of course it would be possible
but it's not going to be done because
it's not necessary
if you discover that there are lemurs
that are actually primates
hi and they can hibernate
perfectly you don't have to freeze a
human you don't have to freeze an organ
you have to turn off their metabolism
like a freaking
lemur and keep it warm dr story
argues that perhaps looking at freeze
tolerance was never the right place to
look
if the goal of freezing is simply to
reduce the cellular needs of organs
maybe there's a way to achieve this
without the freeze
[Music]
when we think of hibernating animals we
often think of cold weather animals like
ground squirrels
but the metabolic rate suppression that
characterizes winter hibernation is not
actually an adaptation to survive the
cold
but to survive periods of drought and
periods with no food
desert animals go through a nearly
identical process called estivation
and this then raises the obvious
question if freezing temperatures aren't
required for metabolic rate suppression
can we bypass the ice altogether can we
simply find a way to shut off the
metabolism of organs to allow them to
last longer
this is the new line of thinking that
ken's story in his lab are investigating
we discovered that primates primates
little tiny monkeys
look called lemurs
they hibernate and turn off their
metabolism completely
but they're not cold they're warm and
adorable
so then we said look why cool down a
human why cool down a human organ why
freeze a human organ
why not just do what a lemur does the
gray mouse lemur
is the particular animal model that the
story lab is currently researching
they are one of a few primate species
that have recently been discovered to
hibernate
and they do so in warm weather every
hibernator you know of
hibernates in the cold oh my god the
bears the ground squirrels
the balls the mice lemurs hibernating
madagascar
it has never been cold in madagascar for
60 million years
but madagascar has two sides the two
sides
are summer and winter but they're wet
and dry
dry and wet wet and dry so the lemurs
run out of food
for six months of the year so they lower
their metabolic rate
and as primates they are the closest
relatives to humans that hibernate
making them the best models for
identifying and applying the mechanism
of metabolic rate suppression to human
needs
the story lab is now focusing on
understanding the biochemistry
involved in warm bodied metabolic rate
suppression
when a lemur finally turns off its
metabolism its body temperature goes
down from your body temperature
37 down to 35. that's not cold
that's warm they turn off their
metabolism with known molecular
mechanisms
known because we study them they turn it
off with microrna
they turn it off by taking message rnas
and putting them in prison
so they develop parts of their cells
which are prisons
for mrna so they can't make any proteins
they do it by phosphorylating and
turning off metabolic pathways
and reorganizing transcription and
translation and they turn it off by
reaching into the nucleus
and making certain dna can't be
developed
any further and while complicated
applying these genetic mechanisms to
human organ transplants
could very well be the thing that saves
tens of thousands of lives every year
the animal kingdom has answers to some
of our biggest problems
hidden within countless species we just
need to ask the right questions
talking with dr story was definitely the
highlight of my week for some obvious
reasons
yes watch this oh look at this yay
watch this hi hi
or my personal thing would be just to
put up pictures
of brad pitt and facebook and because
talking with experts like this gives a
whole new perspective to the story i'm
trying to tell
every science story is driven because of
the people behind it
the ones in the lab or in the field
asking the complicated questions
and these human stories to me are just
as fascinating as the science ones
and this is why we decided to start a
podcast to explore
just this modulus hosted by me
and brian from real engineering is a
podcast about the people behind the
scientific stories we tell you here on
youtube
we talk to the scientists who are on the
cutting edge of research
and the people who are affected by the
topics we discuss
the second episode of modulus launched
yesterday it's an episode where i talked
to two pioneers of the ocean
some of the world's first saturation
divers they discuss the physiological
and psychological effects of living at
the bottom of the ocean for weeks at a
time
they're two of the most interesting
people i've ever had the chance to talk
to and their stories will give you
insight to a whole world that exists at
the bottom of the ocean
this episode of modulus launched
yesterday on nebula
the streaming platform made by me and
several other educational youtube
content creators
it's a place to watch and listen to our
videos and podcasts ad
free along with original content that's
not available anywhere else
like the real engineering series the
logistics of d-day
or tom scott's game show money we can
take more risks on nebula
where we don't have to worry about the
youtube algorithm
there is so much original content there
with more being added all the time
and to make it even better nebula has
partnered with curiosity stream
the streaming platform with thousands of
high budget high quality documentaries
there are loads of documentaries about
extraordinary animal behavior
like this one called nature's weirdest
events made by the bbc
it explores a parasite that can use mind
control on a snail in order to reproduce
the massive amounts of slime made by a
very strange fish
or the incredible architectural
structures made by
huge ant colonies it's a fun 50-minute
documentary with several of these wild
animal stories
if you've hesitated before to get
curiosity stream and never quite pulled
the trigger
now is definitely the time to do it for
a very limited time
curiosity stream is still offering 41
off their annual plans
making a yearly subscription just 11.79
that's less than a dollar per month
there's only a day or so left on this
deal
so get it while it's hot so by signing
up at curiositystream.com
real science you'll get a subscription
to curiosity stream
and a subscription to nebula for just
1179 for the entire
year signing up is also the best way to
support this channel
and all of your favorite educational
content creators
thanks for watching and if you'd like to
see more from me the links to my
instagram twitter and patreon are below
you